the war in afghanistan is officially
over the last american military plane
has left the country and yet the last
american plane did not take the last
american out
according to reports there are hundreds
of americans left in afghanistan if not
more
and yet when you ask the pentagon just
how many americans remain this is the
sort of non-answer you get
i would refer you to the state
department on uh on the the numbers of
americans they're still in contact with
that's that's something for them to
speak to so you can't ask why would the
pentagon know why would we have any you
got to talk to the state department then
you ask the state department they don't
really know either a perfectly botched
end to a perfectly botched withdrawal
but i would not hold my breath for
answers or accountability while
republicans are ready to impeach the
government this government afghanistan's
new taliban government is vowing to
fight climate change
and public school teachers in new york
city of all places are waking up and
protesting the government's incompetence
and power grab i'm michael knowles it's
the michael show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from sunshine cool
water who says isn't it ironic that joe
is now the world's number one issuer of
actual assault weapons without
background checks that is
ironic it's ironic and yet maybe it's
not maybe that's just the way it works
we go around the world arming all sorts
of groups of people some of whom are our
allies at least for a time and then
they're not our allies and maybe they
are our allies again we just arm
everybody except for americans who the
liberal establishment
is trying to disarm
if you want to arm yourself with the
tools that you need to fix your car or
truck i would strongly recommend you
check out rockauto.com how much is your
time worth to you
how much is your money worth to you
would you for instance if you had the
choice would you go spend let's say 25
minutes driving to the auto parts store
at least it might be further than that
right and then another i don't know 10
15 minutes walking around the store
looking for the part and then you don't
find the part and you go
to the guy and you wait in line and then
you say okay finally you wait there
maybe what five ten minutes then you get
to the front of the line and the guy
says okay what kind of car do you have
what kind of part do you need what do
you kind of this and then he goes in the
back let's pray another five ten minutes
then he doesn't have the part and then
he goes online probably to rockauto.com
orders the part charges you twice as
much and you gotta wait for it to arrive
or or you go to rockauto.com super easy
catalog to navigate so simple even i can
do it they've got all the parts it's
same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers reliably low prices
just go to rockauto.com okay right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck right noel scanner wlas in their
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you
so the reporters asked the pentagon hey
pentagon how many
americans are left in afghanistan seems
like if if the final american military
plane is on the way out we should
probably have all the americans right
but you said we don't so how many are
there and they say oh i don't know we
don't know you gotta check with the
state department okay hey secretary of
state anthony blinken how many americans
are left in afghanistan
let me talk briefly about the americans
who remain in afghanistan
we made extraordinary efforts to give
americans every opportunity to depart
the country
in many cases talking and sometimes
walking them into the airport
of those who self-identified as
americans in afghanistan who are
considering leaving the country
we've thus far received confirmation
that about 6 000
have been evacuated or otherwise
departed
this number will likely continue to grow
as our outreach and arrivals continue
we believe there are still a small
number of americans
under 200 and likely closer to 100 who
remain in afghanistan and want to leave
we're trying to determine exactly how
many
we're going through manifests and
calling and texting through our lists
and we'll have more details to share as
soon as possible
okay so they get everyone at first of
all they they start to get the military
out before they get the civilian set
that seems to not make a lot of sense to
me then they finish getting the military
out before they get the civilians out
that seems to make even less sense to me
and then they don't know
how many americans are still there who
want to get out so this is an important
distinction this is going to come up
again in just a second so pay attention
he's he's determining
which americans want to get out and
which americans want to stay now
look i don't know i i'm trying to use my
imagination but i cannot think of very
many reasons
why an american would want to stay in
afghanistan which is not only under
control of the taliban right now but
actually in the midst of another civil
war another civil war in which the
taliban are basically the good guys
i know the taliban were just the bad
guys for at least 20 years before that
they were kind of the good guys also but
at least as we were
trying to figure out our strategy in
afghanistan but right now it's the
taliban versus isis
and isis
much much better than the taliban also
bad taliban is also bad but it's a
little confusing why would an american
want
to stay
lincoln's lincoln says look i don't know
i'm not going to answer why an american
would want to stay but the americans who
do want to stay it's one or two hundred
and look we're doing everything we can
to get them out but you know they've
been look they've been dragging their
feet okay clarissa ward who is
a very impressive reporter with cnn
never thought i would say that she's
still on the ground in afghanistan
and she's the woman who you saw a couple
of weeks ago say you know they're
chanting debt to america but they seem
sort of friendly and she's really doing
great great work out there she is saying
no i've talked to people here
the americans haven't done very much to
get the american civilians out actually
the american civilians haven't been able
to get to the airport
i spoke earlier on in the day with a
family of four from houston texas they
told me they had been going to the
airport for two weeks trying desperately
to get out they all have american
passports they had gone to afghanistan
to visit the mother's family and
essentially the issue was they couldn't
get past the taliban they were in touch
with the us military the military was
trying to facilitate their departure
and they just they couldn't do it they
couldn't get in touch so
we're hearing from the pentagon okay the
pentagon is we're reaching out and then
talk to the state department right the
state department says we're texting and
we're emailing and then you talk to
clarissa ward who's talking to the
actual americans you're saying we're not
getting anything from either the
pentagon or the state department so okay
let's go back to the pentagon hey
pentagon not that spokesman who doesn't
know anything but that other guy okay
hey other guy at the pentagon
what's going on with the american
evacuation
no american citizens came out on the
last what we call the joint tactical
exfiltration the last five jets to leave
we we maintained the ability to bring
them in up until immediately before
departure but we were not able to bring
any americans out that activity ended
probably about 12 hours before our exit
although we continued the outreach and
would have been prepared to to bring
them on until the very last minute but
none of them made it to the airport and
were able to be and were able to be
accommodated so none of them made it to
the airport so the last five planes at
least these are big planes the last five
planes at least
didn't have any american citizens on it
we're doing a really good job
of evacuating afghans
not doing as great a job evacuating
americans
now i want
to to be as fair as i possibly can here
because i think there's a caveat to all
this
that conservatives are not mentioning
because conservatives are trying to just
score political points on joe biden fair
enough joe biden completely botched this
but there is a caveat here which is
there are americans who want to stay in
afghanistan okay
you just heard the pentagon and the
state department refer to
certain americans who have families over
there and who are living with their
families over there and so it's
reminding you many of the americans who
want to stay in afghanistan we're not
talking about barbie and ken okay we're
talking about afghans who have become
american citizens or they're american
passport holders but they still go to
afghanistan they've lived in afghanistan
for a long period of time so it's a
little bit different okay
if you strand an afghan in afghanistan
even if the afghan has gotten american
citizenship it's different than
stranding i don't know a swede in
afghanistan it's just it just looks
different it's different in terms of the
way you can
work with the culture and it's it's
different even in terms of your security
but there's another group of americans
who are going to stay in afghanistan
namely
the cia and other special operators this
is not i i hate to sound like a
conspiracy theorist but this isn't a
conspiracy theory the cia already told
us that they're going to stay cia
director william burns told the senate
intelligence committee back in april
that the cia would not be leaving
afghanistan when the military did quote
the cia will retain a suite of
capabilities some of them remaining in
place so it does seem to me when when
you're hearing from the pentagon and the
state department and all and the white
house for that matter all of this vague
talk how many americans are there's 100
or 300 or i don't know maybe 500 but
i suspect a lot of that is just to give
cover to the special operators that we
have not just in afghanistan but
everywhere else on earth
and so i don't i
i don't want to seem like i'm
defending joe biden's screw up here i
bet there are americans who wanted to
get out whom he left behind i bet there
there was a much better way to do all of
this but also we we do know there are at
least some groups of americans who do
want to stay there namely our special
operators who are not just in
afghanistan but they're they're all over
the place okay
does that does that excuse
what the white house has done here i
don't think so i mean
it seems to me
even if you were going to leave a very
small number of people in afghanistan
intentionally
you would have better messaging because
joe biden said
we would get out
every american before we left
americans should understand that troops
might have to be there beyond august
31st no americans should understand that
we're going to try to get it done before
august 31 but if we don't
the troops if we don't we'll determine
at the time who's left
and
and if they're american forces if
there's american citizens left we're
going to stay to get them all out so you
see joe biden good politician he's been
around for a long time he doesn't want
to answer the question he goes yes so
are you going to get american citizens
out mr president we're going to we're
going to we're going to make sure
you're going to make sure of what well
we're hey we're going to do you know
we're gonna do the thing and we're and
we're gonna and we're gonna take time
and yeah right but sir are you gonna
what are you gonna do you know at the
end of the time if there's still
americans left well we're gonna look
into it okay so mr president what okay
we're gonna stay until we get the map
that was the conclusion now maybe he
shouldn't have said that
because it puts him in a very bad
position right now
it wasn't just biden jen saki said the
same thing
does the president have a sense that
most of the criticism is not of leaving
afghanistan it's the way that he has
ordered it to happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home we are in touch
with them via phone via text via email
via any way that we can possibly reach
americans to get them home if they want
to return home there are no americans
stranded is the white house's official
position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan when i set when we have
been very clear that we are not leaving
americans who want to return home we are
going to bring them home and i think
that's important for the american public
to hear and understand okay it's very
important for the american public to
hear that we will not leave americans
who want to come home in afghanistan
we're going to do it we're obviously
going to do that we're going to leave
them there but i want the american
public to hear that we will not
you know if you want to watch out for
your security i would strongly recommend
you check out ring when you are
in your home let's say you're in the
back of your home when you are at the
office okay let's say maybe you're on
vacation labor day is coming up
and someone goes knock knock knock
it's nice to be able to see and speak to
whoever is at your door if someone's
going around the back of your house
nice to be able to see what's going on
if someone's in your house
really nice to know what's going on you
can do all of that with ring alarm
you can protect your home anytime from
anywhere with ring alarm and it's super
inexpensive not just to get
not just to get the actual product i
love it so much i'm getting it now for a
relative of mine i've given it to
friends of mine as a housewarming gift i
really like it's just pure peace of mind
for me especially when i'm on the road
but you can get it right now even to
protect it you know those old expensive
home security systems you don't need
that anymore okay ring you can keep it
up every month super low price go to
ring.com knowles get a special offer on
a ring alarm security kit today build a
system that's right for your home have
it up and running in minutes ring.com
knowles ring.com
knowles
should joe biden be impeached that is
the question on the minds of
some democrats for that matter but
a lot of republicans right now there's a
senate candidate in ohio
josh mandel who is strong senate
candidate he's looking good he's running
against jd vance over there in ohio
another strong senate candidate and
these are both guys who are
leaning a little bit more into the
conservative wing of the conservative
movement in the republican party
and josh says
we got to impeach joe biden
this has been a colossal failure
in leadership by both the
commander-in-chief joe biden
as well as the generals
a few major
missteps and
complete botches of the withdrawal we're
actually in a situation now where i
believe
biden deserves to be
impeached unlike you know unlike trump
the trump impeachments were complete
politics and you know political theater
whereas
biden has blood on his hands i mean this
guy
is responsible for the blood of young
men and women and leaving behind this
biometric system
is just
one level on a multitude
of failures
okay so what josh is saying here is the
same sort of thing that many republicans
are saying commentators pundits official
ex-officials politicians candidates
they're all saying look the trump
impeachment was stupid
as trump didn't deserve to be impeached
but joe biden does deserve to be
impeached and you say okay well what's
the difference well joe biden deserves
to be impeached because he's done a
really really really bad job
i agree joe biden is doing a really
really really bad job
but i don't agree that he should be
impeached
both on the constitutional level and
also on the practical level
i said this
until i was blue in the face during the
trump impeachment during the trump
impeachments every other two of them
and i'm going to say it again now
because i'm going to be consistent
unlike some of my republican friends and
allies
you don't impeach a president over mal
administration
doing a bad job
is actually not grounds for impeachment
now i know
in in in real life these days at least
for the past
30 years or so yeah a little bit less
than that we
we now impeach people for doing about it
we impeach them for anything it's just a
purely political process but that's not
what the constitution says
in the constitution impeachment is not
supposed to be a purely political
process that you where you could just
get rid of a president because he does a
bad job no matter how bad a job i mean
let's say the worst job possible let's
say he's got the blood of 13 americans
on his hands
you impeach a president for high crimes
and
misdemeanors what is the crime
what crime did he commit he armed the
taliban
uh-huh
sort he didn't it's not as though he
signed over the gear
the taliban
got the the weapons because of the
incompetence of the political decisions
in the american withdrawal that's not a
crime
well he
didn't secure kabul
yeah i agree he should have secured
kabul he should have taken the taliban's
offer to let the americans secure kabul
he shouldn't have let the taliban give
security of kabul over to the haqqani
network which is now part of the taliban
but used to be a separate thing and was
actually one of the largest recipients
of cia funding during the cold war at
least in afghanistan
through the isi in pakistan which also
used to be our ally but it's not our
ally anymore and actually ended up
paying the haqqani network to kill
to attack the cia
it's a bungle it's about bungle actually
going further back than joe biden but he
bears responsibility but it's not
grounds for impeachment
i always hear from my from my often
squishy or republican friends that we've
got to be consistent we can't you know
we gotta treat trump the same way we
would treat biden and frankly i don't
even agree with that
but
as a matter of
i think that we we have a team and i
think that we ought to give a little
more grace to our side but just as a
matter of constitutional
literacy i don't see the high crime or
misdemeanor that joe biden has committed
and then at the practical level beyond
the constitutional
do you want president harris
i don't want president harris i think
president harris is a bad idea i think
that would be worse for the country than
bumbling joe who doesn't know what his
name is who doesn't know what day it is
i i susp by the way joe biden's poll
numbers are tanking right now
leave him in there let those poll
numbers tank let them tank all the way
through 2022. if they keep tanking let
them go through 2024.
i'm not denying i'm not saying i'm pure
as the newly driven snow
when it comes to matters of political
advantage you know in the federal
government
but
it seems right now
to the benefit of
the constitutional order to the benefit
of republicans political chances
to the benefit of our
public policy to keep kamala harris out
of there and to keep joe biden in
just don't think it's a good i i get why
people are angry they have every right
to be angry
but
when we get angry sometimes we make bad
decisions and i think we need to keep
our wits about us
i think it's better just to beat joe
biden at the ballot box if that is
possible
that's a big caveat
because we're
we're not allowed to say
that there was anything wrong with the
2020 election so i'm not google do you
hear me facebook twitter i'm not saying
that there were there was anything wrong
with the 2020 election it was the tote
it was the fairest election ever okay
you hear that but
okay but
uh we've just got reports that they're
they look like they're problems with
about forty four thousand absentee
ballots in georgia
huh that's weird
because i was told everything was
totally fine in georgia even though on
election night and the week after i was
calling it and saying you know georgia
looks pretty shady there looks like
there's some weird stuff going on and we
already found out that in just one batch
of ballots in in just one county in
georgia
you had double counting going on
affected possibly four thousand ballots
we already we saw that we know that for
a fact so now we're talking about forty
four thousand ballots
ballot transfer forms
for nearly forty four thousand ballots
in dekalb county georgia
were either incomplete or were not
filled out in a timely manner by the
time that it was due
according to an analysis performed by
the georgia star news
there were issues with
with around 44 000 ballots three
thousand nine hundred and seven out of
sixty one thousand seven hundred thirty
one absentee ballots cast via dropbox in
dekalb in
the 2020 election
so
two-thirds
of the ballots in this county more than
two-thirds of the ballots in this county
we can't really account for you don't
have the ballot transfer form so you
don't have them completed or you don't
have them in according to the way that
they were supposed to be filled out
and do we think it's just these first of
all
biden barely won
georgia
if if you're of the opinion that biden
won george of fair and square and it was
all totally clean
he certainly didn't do it by much
and so now we're saying okay now 44 000
ballots here are suspect in just one
county what about the other counties
stinks to high heaven
for me this
what is the issue with the ballot
transfer there was an emergency rule
pace passed by the state election board
that said it was renewed in july of 2020
that
you fill out the ballot transfer forms
which are chain of custody documents
they're meant to accompany every batch
of absentee ballots picked up at the
drop boxes and yet these these weren't
filled out so
where did the ballots come from who
filled them out how secure were they
seems a little
dodgy to me because then if anything
happens if there's any question about
the ballots you can't go back and say
okay well who picked them up when were
they picked up what
what was going on here no
no one is allowed to raise
any questions
about whether or not joe biden
got more votes than anyone anywhere ever
this guy
thanks for joining me i'm here uh
the fema director is on uh
15 of director chris well she's on
and i'm here with
with my senior advisor and
boy who knows louisiana very very well
man
that guy joe biden who did who did not
campaign when he did campaign 18 people
showed up he's got his mask hanging off
his face he doesn't know where he is
he's forgetting people's names he's like
i'm here and i'm where oh and then he
calls this black advisor boy that was
that's that's just the cherry on top of
the sundae
and i'm here with hey boy what's your
name boy
i'm huh
and fema
it's fema why oh right because is that
is it super storm that's ah huh
huh
that guy
if you question
whether or not that guy got more votes
than anyone ever and beat donald trump
by the greatest number of votes ever
it was it was a landslide
then you're a terrorist you're
undermining our democracy if you raise
any questions about election laws not
being followed you're you're an
insurrectionist
undermining democracy i don't do people
buy that anymore i don't subscribe
and start listening now to morning wire
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts and leave a five-star review
if you like what you hear
if you want the news that no other media
outlet covers then i highly recommend
you sign up for daily wire readers pass
if you sign up today you will get a free
four week trial you'll unlock exclusive
access to editorial content that just
does not exist anywhere else after that
trial is up
the price is just four bucks a month
it's nothing
less than a cup of coffee at most fancy
coffee places actually it's less than a
cup of coffee even at the cheap coffee
places because of bite inflation
sign up right now for your readers past
dailywire.com subscribe hurry because
our four week free trial ends today
august 31st we'll be right back with a
lot more
joe biden just got in a little bit of
trouble it's not real trouble it's like
fake trouble on the right it's among
conservatives i bet people on the left
didn't even see this clip but but joe
biden was
discussing the superstorm he was
discussing the fema director and then he
referred to a senior advisor of his who
is black as boy he's a boy who knows
louisiana
and you're not supposed to call black
people boy
because this was uh
derogatory that way back in the day and
now people don't even really remember
that but it's joe bi is a racist see
that's that's what we're supposed to say
that's what we're supposed to conclude
from this no you know what we're the
first thing we're supposed to say is
if a republican ever called a black
advisor boy oh gosh could you imagine if
the shoe were on the other foot could
you imagine the outrage but there's not
outrage because the left they're
hypocritical
okay
yeah you're right you're right yeah
you're right if a republican did that it
would be a big outrage and be on the
news and he'd be called a racist but joe
biden did it and so he's not called a
racist and so
so what
so what
everybody knows that joe biden didn't
mean anything by it nobody thinks that
joe biden is
you know
a klansman or something
nobody believes it it's all just fake
by the way the libs
don't care when you call them racist
they don't the libs who actually do
favor
racial discrimination in the law the
libs who actually do think there ought
to be a racial caste system
the libs who if racism has any meaning
whatsoever anymore are racist they don't
care
but we do care we conservatives do care
it's the worst thing you can be called
in america today
if you're a conservative at least you
could be ostracized you could lose your
job you could lose your reputation if
you're a racist
and so we really you know if a
republican actually said oh man this boy
man i love this boy see who are you
calling boy oh no i'm not a racist
please don't call me a racist i think we
got to stop
caring about that racism if it has any
meaning at all is
hatred of people on the basis of their
race right so if you're not that that's
an offense against human dignity so
that's why it's wrong and simple so if
you're not doing that then who cares if
they call you a racist or they i mean
they called ronald reagan and neo-nazi
okay and george bush and
donald trump and they're going to do it
to ron desantis or ted cruz they've
already done it to ted cruz they're
doing it to josh hawley
they're going to do it to whoever is the
next guy
so
who cares
who cares i just i think we need to stop
wasting our breath on this stuff okay i
mean it's funny because i'm not talking
about it but i'm talking about it as a
political strategy i'm not i'm not
talking about it as though joe biden is
now the leader of the ku klux klan or
something like that because he's not
it's just it's a cheap political
attack no one really believes at least
of all the left they're the ones who
invented the attack
so just cut it out okay everything's
racist even anti-racism so you know
i
i know it's complicated but there was
racism right
and then there was not
being a racist so you're either a racist
or you're not a racist but then in the
last few years that's not good enough
it's not good enough to be not a racist
we hear from ibram kendi and robin
d'angelo and all the other
hustlers so now you you gotta be an
anti-racist
but then what i just learned yesterday
this one's gonna shock you
is that anti-racism
is racist
trish farley she's a white woman who uh
i met when i joined when i started
working with the people's institute of
survival beyond and um she calls herself
and i'm borrowing this from her but it
just she calls herself a racist
anti-racist
and i really love that term as a white
woman because
again you know this and you know for
those people familiar with the people's
institute the definition of racism
as defined by them is race prejudice
plus power equals racism so
in that definition i i am as a white
person a racist it doesn't mean that i'm
purposely that my beliefs are purposeful
and i'm doing things on purpose and yet
i can't be a white person living in the
society and not be benefiting from
racism so
i i kind of so i love that term of you
know i'm a racist anti-racist i'm a
racist anti-racist so what she's saying
she actually didn't define it
precisely
even according to her own kooky
definition
she is saying that
you need power it's not just enough to
have racial prejudice black people might
hate white people but but we're defining
black people as not having any power
here so
they can't be racist
you need you need power in order to be
racist so the only racists according to
this definition because white people are
defined as the only ones with power the
only racists or white people but she
goes further she doesn't just say that
all racists are white people she's
saying all white people are racists that
even she as an anti-racist
is a racist because white people can
never overcome their racism even if they
become very conscious of it even if they
become
activists on anti-racism they still
can't overcome their
racism which
implies to me that maybe we should just
give it up then who cares if it's not
possible if all white people are racist
and they cannot ameliorate this in any
way they can't overcome it then all
right i guess that's just how we are
okay
where's the nearest hood because i'm
told
by reliable sources that i there's no
way to overcome it so why would i try if
you're telling me it's a futile attempt
but but more there's something even
stupider about what she's saying
which is that it violates
aristotle's law of non-contradiction you
can't to two contradictory things cannot
simultaneously be true to mutually
contradictory things can't at the same
time be true i cannot at the same time
be a racist and an anti-racist it's not
possible
i i can't do it
just like
a this this leftist year's tumbler
cannot at the same time be black and
white
right
to keep with our
color and hue analogy it can't at the
same time be black and white
because those are mutually exclusive
things they would contradict one another
it's not gray right it's not it's
it's i either one or the other something
cannot at the same time be true and
false
it has to be
one or the other
but they don't know that they don't know
that so it's all racist
it's all anti-racist it's all
it's lunacy it's lunacy and this is why
by the way when you hear about critical
race theory or you hear about some of
this activism in the schools
one thing that keeps cropping up in all
the pamphlets and all the lessons and
all the powerpoints is this idea that
there is no objective truth
you remember that in in one of the
anti-racist pamphlets from the
smithsonian they said that objective
truth
reality reason
these are white supremacist dog whistles
why it's not just a funny quirk of of
this activism
this activism this ideology
must undermine objective truth it must
undermine logic it must undermine reason
because if you have logic if you have
reason if there is objective truth
then the ideology doesn't make sense
if there is such a thing as logic then
you cannot be an anti-racist racist a
racist anti-racist
ist-ist anti-anti-this that and the
other thing
now speaking of woke lunatics
this is not just affecting the
weird videos on youtube it's not just
affecting
obviously neurotic hysterical liberal
white women
or i guess the host of that was a black
woman
but it's not it's not just affecting
affluent
suburban middle class libs it's
affecting our children everywhere
there's a gal who just went
went viral
thanks to our friends at libs of tick
tock
she she posted a tick tock she's a
teacher
and she says you know in the class my
kids are you know they're supposed to
say the pledge of allegiance at least in
some schools you're still supposed to do
that
but we don't have an american flag in
our class we've got a very different
flag
during third period we have
announcements and they do the pledge of
allegiance i always tell my class
stand if you feel like it don't stand if
you feel like it say the words if you
want don't have to say the words so my
class decided to stand but not say the
words totally fine except for the fact
that my room does not have a flag it
used to be there but i took it down
during covid
because it made me uncomfortable
and um
i packed it away and i don't know where
and i haven't found it yet
but my kid today goes hey um it's kind
of weird that we just stand and then you
know we say it to nothing and i'm like
oh well you know i gotta find it like
i'm working on it i got you
in the meantime i tell this kid
we do have a flag in the class that you
can
pledge your allegiance to and he like
looks around he goes
oh that one
and it's the pride progress flag which
is different it's not just the rainbow
flag it's the rainbow flag with a bunch
of other colors and it makes it like a
racial thing and it's a flag to the
allegedly universal
radical leftist ideology okay
there was a
i think he calls himself a conservative
columnist but he's much more either
centrist or really center left conor
friedersdorf i believe is his name and
he
he came out and posted on twitter about
this and he said you know this is cancel
culture stop
shaming this random teacher this is we
shouldn't we conservatives shouldn't
be engaging in cancel culture
and i think that is a that is not right
i think that's a very
i hate to be harsh i think that's a very
shallow take as as you know in my book
speechless
number one national bestseller thanks to
all of you who ordered the book and read
it appreciate it
i
think that the way we talk about cancel
culture is very silly because all
cultures cancel all cultures have
standards and taboos
if a culture pledges allegiance to one
flag which is a symbol of a country it's
a symbol of a way of life it's a symbol
of certain values and traditions
then it is
necessarily excluding
other
values traditions nations ways of life
if you pledge allegiance to one flag you
are excluding other flags
this teacher has made a decision she is
not going to put the american flag in
her classroom she doesn't like america
she doesn't think her students should
have any particular allegiance to
america she thinks that
that students should have allegiance to
radical leftism
which ought to replace america
it's it's a flag that's not it's not a
national flag the pride progress flag
it's an imperial flag it's saying that
these values this this idea
is true everywhere on earth
it's just as true and just as good as
just as valid in timbuktu as it is here
whereas that would not be the case for
the american flag a national flag
so she says that's what you're going to
pledge your allegiance to hee-hee giggle
giggle giggle
this is a woman who is paid presumably
by our tax dollars
she is a citizen of our country she has
obligations to our country she's she's
educating
a generation of children and she's doing
a very poor job of it she's educating
them in the wrong way that is not
satisfactory
not acceptable for future americans and
she should be fired
she should be canceled it's good it's
really good to cancel some people and
some things
as as bill buckley said if uh if a nazi
were teaching sociology
at yale when he was fired no one would
call it cancel culture okay
and we we understand that that's true
for things on the far right or
politically unclassifiable things but we
we don't accept that that's true for
things on the left and the left does
understand that which is why the left
has taken over the whole culture and has
really taken over our whole politics
that teacher should be fired that video
should go viral she should at the very
least be reprimanded that flag should be
ripped down and
desecrated the pride progress one and
she should
be forced to put the american flag up
there and then those students should be
forced to stand up and pledge allegiance
to their country
and if they don't like their country
they can either get out when they're
little kids so they'll probably need
their parents to go get out or if they
don't like their country and a lot of
people are a little upset with our
country right now then they need to make
it better but they have an obligation to
it
because it's their country
and and we have an obligation to our
families and to our communities to our
states
and to our country
and we have a responsibility to make our
country a little bit better
now it's not all bad news with teachers
these days we're getting a lot of bad
news out of the classroom
the teacher unions oh my gosh that's a
complete disaster
the teacher unions are
shut down all all of the schools are a
great many of the schools for for much
of last year
but the teachers themselves
they're fighting back they're fighting
back against keeping the schools shut
down
they're fighting back
against
liberal governments and specifically
they're fighting back against
all these covid mandates
mask vax mandates coming out of new york
city new york city public school
teachers
protesting their government's liberal
policies
new york city teachers take to i can't i
can't quite i guess it's around city
hall it's that around like brooklyn
bridge city hall like i used to live
right around there the new york city
public school teachers take a listen to
what they're chanting
we work for the doe and they're telling
us that we can't come to work unless
we're fully vaccinated
and we worked all year without a vaccine
our children were protected
we've done everything that we've been
asked and we worked during an entire
pandemic and we were okay so now they're
switching things up on us and we're
angry i'm a centrist i like liberty and
i prefer to die a free man
[Applause]
i am prepared to end this now and i am
officially announcing my exit from the
ufc i love that this lady's got a baby
[Applause]
so your question was am i prepared to
lose it all
and the answer is yes
because i there's another teacher i
believe that this is just about a
vaccine
i do not believe that this is just about
our health
this is about medical freedom this is
about totalitarianism that's right bingo
baby totally right
so these are new york city teachers
these are people who work for the
department of education these are
left-wingers in some ways by the way you
saw the rainbow flag up there not the
pride progress flag but the other the
old pride flag the rainbow flag these
are people in new york city
something tells me that these are not
die-hard rock-ribbed republicans okay
but they're recognizing this isn't about
a vaccine this isn't about an epidemic
this is about
medical freedom this is about our right
as people
and
educators
to make medical decisions for ourselves
especially when you're when you're
making a prudential judgment right
when you're looking at an experimental
drug that doesn't particularly stop
transmission of the virus doesn't
particularly stop infection of the virus
but it does ostensibly mitigate some of
the worst effects of the virus
which we're not really at risk of
because we're generally young healthy
people over here
so they're using their their common
sense
i can say this as a new yorker a lot of
people
do not believe this or they're just not
familiar with it
there is a weird kind of conservatism to
new york
and i think this weird kind of
conservatism that is not republican that
probably didn't vote for trump that
is not
they wouldn't call themselves
conservative
i think it's true of a lot of places in
america
okay
what you're going to hear if if the
story even comes up is that oh yeah it
was just some right wing teachers that
showed up do those teachers look or
sound right wing to you they don't to me
and this video is not from some
right-wing provocateur it's from the
associated press it's from a left-wing
news outlet
there's this common sense even in new
york where you say you know don't don't
make me take this experimental drug for
a cough that doesn't really threaten me
all that much yes i know that there's
some risk i'm willing to assume that
risk okay
that's that's i'm i'm making a judgment
and i'm not crazy all right and actually
i think i've got better judgment than
the fouches of the world actually i
think i've got better judgment than the
bidens of the world so leave me alone
okay leave me alone
look we're
we're all in this together we're all you
know we're all americans we're all new
yorkers we've got some kind of
solidarity but on this issue this just
seems like a little too much to me i
think that's true of a lot of people and
i think you saw them
donald trump got a fair number of these
people throughout the country in 2016
and ronald reagan got a fair number of
them
in 1980 it's not the
bow tie wearing think tank ideological
rigid conservative it's just
a little bit of common sense that is the
hope that's the hope for the country
by the way our our wonderful
administrative agencies the public
health experts
they're saying some things that don't
seem totally true so the cdc on on
monday just yesterday claimed that there
were no deaths reported in young people
due to heart inflammation conditions
which is a known and acknowledged side
effect of the pfizer and madonna
vaccines
that is obviously not true
now the cdc might say
well look we haven't proven that any of
these are directly related that i guess
that would be true if they haven't
proven it
but on this show
we talked in july about how the cdc was
investigating the death of a 13 year old
boy who died suddenly in his sleep two
days after receiving the pfizer vaccine
his preliminary autopsy findings showed
that his heart was enlarged when he died
and there was fluid around his heart
which is the side effect that is
acknowledged even by the cdc
so sure you want to tell me there's no
proven 100 certain evidence that this is
killing young people by enlarging their
hearts after they took the vaccine okay
you can tell me that if you want but
don't tell me that it's not being
reported it is being reported and you
people acknowledged it
last month you acknowledged it is is the
memory hole that effective that now we
forget things that you said one month
ago this is why people don't trust you
this is why even liberal new york city
school teachers are coming out and
saying
no thank you
no thank you now speaking of public
health this kind of this really ties it
together
joe biden amid all the crazy national
problems is launching a new office of
the department of health and human
services to confront
climate change
hmm what why huh
didn't i didn't think that
the sun monster was really affecting my
health i didn't think that was in the
purview of health and human services but
that's what he's doing it's the office
of climate change and health equity
quote to address the impact of climate
change on the health of the american
people and establish an interagency
working group to decrease the risk of
climate change okay
as i have you know i hate to say i told
you so as i've told you from the
beginning of this epidemic public health
is the perfect way
for the left to impose its will on the
american people to subvert the
constitutional order to grab a lot of
power
because public health can mean anything
and public health is not run by the
people it's just run by a handful of
egghead experts who are unaccountable so
then everything becomes public health
just like everything is infrastructure
now everything's part of public health
climate change was always
effective for them in this regard too
because it's an unfalsifiable hypothesis
and
it
does not count on the decision-making
powers of the people it's only about the
decisions of experts
the taliban just came out they said
they're going to work to confront
climate change why because it's an
effective power grab and that's what's
going on and it's been going on for 18
months and it's been going on longer
than that
and the left is very effective at that
they might they might botch
evacuations they might botch
their
following of the constitutional process
in elections and elsewhere but they're
pretty good at taking power and i think
we need to get good taking that power
back i'm michael and also the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bouran our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show american troops leave
afghanistan and leave hundreds of
americans thousands of green card
holders and tens of thousands of afghan
allies behind the biden white house pats
itself on the back for a job well done
and the taliban are flying around our
helicopters that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen